you've probably read in the news that
deep learning is the secret recipe
behind many exciting developments
and has made many of our world's dreams
and perhaps also nightmares come true
who would have thought that deep minds
alphago could be at least a doll
in a boat game which boasts in more
possible moves than there are atoms in
the entire universe
a lot of people including me never saw
it coming it seemed impossible
but it's here now deep learning is
everywhere it's beating physicians are
diagnosing cancer
it's responsible for translating web
pages in a matter of mere seconds
to the autonomous vehicles by weimo and
tesla
hi my name is jason and welcome to this
course in deep learning
where you'll learn everything you need
to get started with deep learning in
python
how to build remarkable algorithms
capable of solving complex problems
that weren't possible just a few decades
ago we'll talk about what deep learning
is
and the difference between artificial
intelligence and machine learning
i'll introduce new networks what they
are and just how essential they are to
deep learning
you're going to learn about how deep
learning models train and learn
and the various types of learning
associated supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
we're going to talk about loss functions
optimizers the grading descent algorithm
the different types of neural network
architectures and the various steps
involved in deep learning
this entire course is centered on the
notion of deep learning
but what is it deep learning is a subset
of machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
which involves more traditional methods
to learn representations
directly from data machine learning
involves teaching computers to recognize
patterns in data
in the same way as our brains do so as
humans it's easy for us to distinguish
between a cat and a dog
but it's much more difficult to teach a
machine to do this and we'll talk more
about this later on in this course
before i do that i want to give you a
sense of the amazing successes of deep
learning in the past
in 1997 gary kasparov the most
successful champion in the history of
chess
lost to ibm's deep blue one of the first
computer or artificial systems
it was the first defeat of a reigning
world chess champion by a computer
in 2011 ibm's watson competed in game
show
jeopardy against his champions brad
rotter and ken jennings
and won the first prize a million
dollars
in 2015 alphago a deep learning computer
program created by google's deepmind
division
defeated lisa dole an 18 time world
champion at go
a game of google more times complex than
chess
but deep learning can do more than just
betas at boat games it finds
applications anywhere from self-driving
vehicles
to fake news detection to even
predicting earthquakes
these were astonishing moments not only
because machines beat humans at their
own games
but because of the endless possibilities
that they opened up
what followed such events have been a
series of striking breakthroughs in
artificial intelligence
machine learning and yes deep learning
to put it simply deep learning is a
machine learning technique that learns
features and tasks directly from data
by running inputs through a biologically
inspired neural network architecture
these neural networks contain a number
of hidden layers through which data is
processed
allowing for the machine to go deep in
its learning making connections
and weighing input for the best results
we'll go over neural networks in the
next video
so why deep learning the problem with
traditional machine learning algorithms
is that no matter how complex they get
they'll always be machine like they need
a lot of domain expertise
human intervention and are only capable
of what they're designed for
for example if i show you the image of a
face you will automatically recognize
it's a face
but how would a computer know what this
is well if we follow traditional machine
learning
we'd have to manually and painstakingly
define to a computer what it faces
for example it has eyes ears and mouth
but now how do you define an eye or a
mouth to a computer
well if you look at an eye the corners
are at some angle
they're definitely not 90 degrees
they're definitely not zero degrees
there's some angle in between so we
could work with that and train our
classifier
to recognize these kinds of lines in
certain orientations
this is complicated for ei practitioners
and the rest of the world
that's where deep learning holds a bit
of promise the key idea in deep learning
is that you can learn these features
just from raw data
so i can feed a bunch of images or faces
to my deep learning algorithm
and it's going to develop some kind of
hierarchical representation of detecting
lines and edges
and then using these lines and edges to
detect eyes and a mouth
and composing it together to ultimately
detect the face
as it turns out the underlying
algorithms for training these models
have existed for quite a long time
so why has deep learning gaining
popularity many decades later
well for one data has become much more
pervasive
we're living in the age of big data and
these algorithms require
massive amounts of data to effectively
be implemented
second we have hardware and architecture
that are capable of handling the vast
amount of data
and computational power that these
algorithms require
hardware that simply wasn't available a
few decades ago
third building and deploying these
algorithms models as i call
is extremely streamlined with the
increasing popularity
of open source software like tensorflow
and pytorch
deep learning models refer to the
training of things called neural
networks
neural networks form the basis of deep
learning a sub-field of machine learning
where algorithms are inspired by the
structure of the human brain
just like neurons make up the brain the
fundamental building blocks of a neural
network
is also a neuron neural networks take in
data
they train themselves to recognize
patterns in this data and predict
outputs for a new set of similar data
in a new network information propagates
through three central components that
form the basis
of every neural network architecture the
input layer
the output layer and several hidden
layers between the two
in the next video we'll go over the
learning process of a neural network
the learning process of a neural network
can be broken into two main processes
forward propagation and back propagation
full propagation is the propagation of
information from the input
layer to the output layer we can define
our input layer as several neurons
x1 through xn these neurons connect to
the neurons of the next layer
through channels and they are assigned
numerical values called weights
the inputs are multiplied to the weights
and their sum is sent as input to the
neurons in the hidden layer
where each neuron in turn is associated
to a numerical value called the bias
which is then added to the input sum
this weighted sum is then passed through
a non-linear function called the
activation function
which essentially decides if that
particular neuron can contribute to the
next layer
in the output layer it's basically a
form of probability
the neuron with the highest value
determines what the output finally is
so let's go over a few terms the weight
of a neuron tells us how
important the neuron is the higher the
value the more important it is in the
relationship
the bias is like the new on having an
opinion to the relationship
it serves to shift the activation
function to the right or to the left
if you have had some experience with
high school math you should know that
adding a scalar value to a function
shifts a graph either to the left or to
the right and this is exactly what the
bias does it shifts the activation
function to the right
or to the left that propagation is
almost like for propagation
except in the reverse direction
information here is passed from the
output layer
to the hidden layers not the input layer
but what information gets passed on from
the output layer
isn't the output layer supposed to be
the final layer where we get the final
output
well yes but no bad propagation is the
reason why new networks is so powerful
it is the reason why new networks can
learn by themselves
in the last step before propagation a
new network spits out a prediction
this prediction could have two
possibilities either right
or wrong in bad propagation the new
network evaluates its own performance
and checks if it is right
or wrong if it is wrong the network uses
something called a loss function
to quantify the deviation from the
expected output
and it is this information that's sent
back to the hidden layers
for the weights and biases to be
adjusted so that the network's accuracy
level
increases let's visualize the training
process with a real example
let's suppose we have a data set this
dataset gives us the weight of a vehicle
and the number of goods carried by that
vehicle and also tells us if those
vehicles are cars or trucks
we want to go through this data trade a
new networks to predict
cars or trucks based on their weights
and goods to start off let's initialize
the neural network by giving it random
weights and biases
these can be anything we really don't
care what these values are
as long as they're there in the first
entry of a data set
we have vehicle weight equal to a value
which in this case is 15
and good as two according to this
it's a car we now start moving these
input dimensions through the newer
network
so basically what we want to do is take
both the inputs multiply them by their
weight
and add a bias and this is where the
magic happens
we run this weighted sum through an
activation function
okay now let's say that the output of
this activation function
is 0.001 this again
is multiplied by the weight and added to
the bias and
finally in the output layer we have a
guess
now according to this neural network the
type of vehicle with weight 15 and goods
2
has a greater probability of being a
truck of course this is not true and a
new network knows this
so we use back propagation we're going
to quantify the difference
between the expected result and the
predicted output using a loss function
in bank propagation we're going to go
backwards and adjust our initial rates
and biases
remember that during the initialization
of the neural network we chose
completely random weight and biases
well during back propagation these
values will be adjusted to better fit
the prediction model
okay so that was one iteration through
the first piece of the data set
in the second entry we have vehicle
weight 34 and goods
67. we're going to use the same process
as before
multiply the input with the weight and
add a box pass this result
into an activation function and repeat
till the output layer
check the error difference and employ
back propagation to adjust the weights
in the biases
your new network will continue doing
this repeated processor for propagation
calculating the error and then back
propagation for as many entries there
are in this data set
the more data you give the newer network
the better it will be at predicting the
right output
but there's a tradeoff because too much
data and you'll end up with a problem
like overfitting which i'll discuss
later in this course
but that's essentially how a new network
works you feed input
the network initializes with random
weights and biases that are adjusted
each time during back propagation until
the network's gone through all your data
and is now able to make predictions
this learning algorithm can be
summarized as follows first we
initialize the network with random
values
for the network's parameters or the
weights in the biases
we take a set of input data and pass
them through the network
we compare these predictions obtained
with the values of the expected labels
and calculate the loss using a loss
function
we perform back propagation in order to
propagate this loss to each and every
weight and bias we use this propagated
information to update the weights and
biases of neural network
with the gradient descent algorithm in
such a way that the total loss is
reduced
and a better model is obtained the last
step is continue iterating the previous
steps
until we consider that we have a good
enough model
in this section we're going to talk
about the most common terminologies used
in deep learning today
let's start off with the activation
function
the activation function serves to
introduce something called non-linearity
into the network
and also decides whether a particular
neuron can contribute to the next layer
but how do you decide if the neuron can
fire or activate
well we had a couple of ideas which led
to the creation of different activation
functions
the first idea we had is how about we
activate the neuron
if it is above a certain value or
threshold if it is less than the
threshold
don't activate it activation function a
is equal to activated if y is greater
than some threshold
else it's not this is essentially a step
function
its output is 1 or activated when value
is greater than 0.
its output is activated when value is
greater than some threshold
and outputs not activated otherwise
great so this makes an activation
function for a neuron
no confusions life is perfect except
there are some drawbacks with this
to understand about it think about the
following think about a case
where you want to classify multiple such
neurons into classes
say class 1 class 2 class 3 etc
what will happen if more than one neuron
is activated
all these neurons will output a one well
how do you decide now how do you decide
which class it belongs to
it's complicated right you would want
the network to activate only one neuron
and the other should be zero only then
you would be able to say it was
classified properly
in real practice however it is harder to
train and converge it this way
it would be better if the activation was
not binary and instead some probable
value like 75
activated or 16 activated there's a 75
chance that it belongs to class 2 etc
then if more than one neuron activates
you could find which neuron fires based
on which has the highest probability
okay maybe you'll ask yourself i want
something to give me a more analog value
rather than just saying activated or not
activated
something other than in binary and maybe
you would have thought about a linear
function a straight line function where
the activation is proportional to the
input
by a value called the slope of the line
this way it gives us a range of
activations so it isn't binary
activation
we can definitely connect a few neurons
together and if more than one
fires we could take the maximum value
and decide based on that
so that is okay too and what is the
problem with this
well if you are familiar with gradient
descent which i'll come to in just a bit
you'll notice that the derivative of a
linear function is a constant
makes sense because the slope isn't
changing at any point
for a function f of x is equal to mx
plus c the derivative
is m this means that the gradient has no
relationship
whatsoever with x this also means that
during back propagation
the adjustments made to the weights and
the biases aren't dependent on
x at all and this is not a good thing
additionally think about if you have
connected layers no matter how many
layers you have
if all of them are linear in nature the
activation function of the final layer
is nothing but just a linear function of
the input of the first layer
pause for a bit and think about it this
means that the entire neural network of
dozens of layers
can be replaced by a single layer
remember a combination of linear
functions in the linear manner
is still another linear function and
this is terrible because we've just lost
the ability to stack layers this way
no matter how much we stack the whole
network is still equivalent to a single
layer
with single activation next we have a
sigmoid function and if you've ever
watched a video on activation functions
this is the kind of function used in the
examples a sigmoid function is defined
as a if x is equal to 1 over 1 plus e to
the negative x
well this looks smooth and kind of like
a step function what are its benefits
think about it for a moment well first
things first it has non-linear nature
combinations of this function are also
non-linear great so now we can stack
layers
what about non-binary activations yes
that too
this function outputs an analog
activation unlike the step function
and also has a smooth gradient an
advantage of this activation function is
that unlike the linear function
the output of this function is going to
be in the range zero to one
inclusive compared to the negative
infinity to infinity of the latter
so we have activations bound in a range
and this won't blow up the activations
and this is great and sigmoid functions
are one of the most widely used
activation functions today
but life isn't always rosy and sigmoids
two tend to have the share of
disadvantages
if you look closely between x is equal
to negative two and x is equal to two
the y values are very steep any small
changes in
values of x in that region will cause
values of y to change drastically
also towards either end of the function
the y values tend to respond very less
to changes in x
the gradient at those regions is going
to be really really small
almost zero and it gives rise to the
vanishing gradient problem
which just says that if the input to the
activation function is either large
or small the sigmoids are going to
squish that down to a value between zero
and one and the gradient of this
function becomes really small
and you'll see why when we talk about
gradient descent this is a huge
problem another activation function that
is used is the tan h function
this looks very similar to sigmoid in
fact
mathematically this is what's known as a
shifted sigmoid function
okay so like the sigmoid it has
characteristics that we discussed above
it is nonlinear nature so we can stack
layers
it is bound to arrange from negative one
to one so there's no worrying about the
activations blowing up
the derivative of the tanning function
however is steeper than that of the
sigmoid
so deciding between the sigmoid and the
tanh will really depend on your
requirement of the gradient strength
like sigmoid tanh is also a very popular
and widely used activation function
and yes like the sigmoid tanh does have
a vanishing gradient problem
the rectified linear unit or the value
function is defined as a of x is equal
to the max
from 0 to x at first look this would
look like a linear function right the
graph is linear in the positive axis
let me tell you rather is in fact
non-linear nature
and combinations of relu are also
non-linear
great so this means that we can stack
layers however
unlike the previous two functions that
we discussed is not bounded the range of
the relu is from zero to infinity
this means there is a chance of blowing
up the activation
another point i would like to discuss
here is sparsity of
inactivation imagine a big neural
network with lots of neurons
using a sigmoid or a tanning will cause
almost all the neurons to fire in an
analog
way this means that almost all
activations will be processed to
describe the network's output
in other words the activation would be
dense
and this is costly ideally we want only
a few neurons in the network to activate
and thereby making the activations pass
and efficient
here's where the relu comes in imagine a
network with randomly initialized
weights
and almost 50 percent of the network
yields zero activation
because of the characteristic relu it
outputs zero for negative values of x
this means that only 50 percent of the
neurons fire
sparse activation making the network
lighter but when life gives you an apple
it comes with a little worm inside
because of that horizontal line in relu
for negative values of x
the gradient is zero in that region
which means that during back propagation
the weights will not get adjusted during
descent
this means that those neurons which go
into that state will stop responding to
variations in the error
simply because the gradient is zero
nothing changes
this is called the dying value problem
this problem can cause several neurons
to just
die and not respond thus making a
substantial part of the network passive
rather than what we want out of there
are workarounds for this one way
especially is to simply make the
horizontal line into a non-horizontal
component
by adding a slope usually the slope is
around 0.001
and this this new version of the relu is
called
leaky value the main idea is that the
gradient should never be zero
one major advantage of the relu is the
fact that it's less computationally
expensive than functions like tannage
and sigmoid
because it involves simpler mathematical
operations
this is a really good point to consider
when you were designing your own deep
neural networks
great so now the question is which
activation function to use
because of the advantages that relu
offers does this mean that you should
use reload for everything you do
or could you consider sigmoid and tan h
well
both when you know the function that
you're trying to approximate has certain
characteristics
you should choose an activation function
with which will approximate the function
faster
leading to faster training processes for
example a sigmoid function works well
for binary classification problems
because approximating our classifier
functions as combinations of the sigmoid
is easier than maybe the relu this will
lead to faster training processes and
larger convergence
you can use your own custom functions
too if you don't know the nature of the
function you're trying to learn
i would suggest you start with relu and
then work backwards from there
before we move on to the next section i
want to talk about why we use
non-linear activation functions as
opposed to linear ones
if you recall in my definition of
activation functions
i mentioned that activation functions
serve to introduce something called
non-linearity in the network for all
intensive purposes
introducing non-linearity simply means
that your activation function must be
non-linear
that is not a straight line
mathematically linear functions are
polynomials of degree 1
that when graphed in the x y plane are
straight lines inclined to the x-axis at
a certain value
we call this the slope of the line
non-linear functions are polynomials of
degree greater than one
and when graphed they don't form
straight lines rather than more curved
if we use linear activation functions to
model our data
then no matter how many hidden layers
our network has it will always become
equivalent to having a single layer
network
and in deep learning we want to be able
to model every type of data
without being restricted as would be the
case should we use linear functions
we discussed previously in the learning
process of neural networks
that we started with random weight and
biases the neural network makes a
prediction
this prediction is compared against the
expected output and the weights and
biases are adjusted accordingly
well loss functions are the reason that
we're able to calculate that difference
really simply a loss function is a way
to quantify the deviation of the
predicted output by the neural network
to the expected output it's as simple as
that nothing mo
nothing less there are plenty of loss
functions out there for example under
regression we have squared error loss
absolute ever loss in huber loss in
binary classification we have binary
cross
entropy and hinge loss in multi-class
classification problems we have the
multi-class
cross entropy and the callback liability
divergence loss and so on
the choice of the best function really
depends on what kind of project you're
working on
different projects require different
loss functions now i don't want to talk
any further loss functions right now
we'll do this under the optimization
section because that's really where most
functions are utilized
in the previous section we dealt with
loss functions which are mathematical
ways of measuring how
wrong predictions made by neural network
are
during the training process we tweak and
change the parameters or the weights of
the model
to try and minimize that loss function
and make our predictions as correct
and optimized as possible but how
exactly do you do that
how do you change the parameters of your
model by how much
and when we have the ingredients how do
we make the cake
this is where optimizers come in they
tied together the loss function and
model parameters or the weight and
biases
by updating the network in response to
the output of the loss function
in simpler terms optimizers shape and
mold your model
into more accurate models by adjusting
the weights and the biases
the loss function is its guide it tells
the optimizer whether it's moving in the
right
or the wrong direction to understand
this better
imagine did you have just killed mount
everest and now you decide to descend
the mountain blindfolded
it's impossible to know which direction
to go in you could either go
up which is away from your goal or go
down which is towards your goal
but to begin you would start taking
steps using your feet
you'll be able to gauge whether you're
going up or down
in this analogy you resemble the neural
network
going down your goal is trying to
minimize the error
and your feet are resemblance of the
loss functions they measure whether
you're going in the right way or the
wrong way
similarly it's impossible to know what
your model's weights should be
right from the start but with some trial
and error based on the loss function
you could end up getting there
eventually we now come to grading
descent
often called the grand daddy of
optimizers
grading descent is an iterative
algorithm that starts up at a random
point in the loss function
and travels down its slope in steps
until it reaches the lowest point or the
minimum of the function
it is the most popular optimizer we use
nowadays it's fast
robust and flexible and here's how it
works
first we calculated what a small change
in each individual weight would do to
the loss function
we adjust each individual weight based
on its gradient
that is take a small step in the
determined direction
the last step is to repeat the first and
the second step
until the loss function gets as low as
possible i want to talk about this
notion of a gradient
the gradient of a function is the vector
of the partial derivatives with respect
to all
independent variables the gradient
always points
in the direction of the steepest
increase in the function
suppose we have a graph like so with
loss on the y-axis
and the value of the weight on the
x-axis we have a little data
point here that corresponds to the
randomly initialized weight
to minimize this loss that is to get
this data point to the minimum of the
function
we need to take the negative gradient
since we want to find the steepest
decrease in function
this process happens iteratively through
the losses as minimized as possible
and that's grading descent in a nutshell
when dealing with high dimensional data
sets
that is a lot of variables it's possible
you'll find yourself in an area where it
seems like you've reached the lowest
possible value for your loss function
but in reality it's just a local minimum
to avoid getting stuck in a local minima
we make sure we use the proper learning
rate
changing our weights too fast by adding
or subtracting too much
that is taking steps that are too large
or too small
can hinder your ability to minimize the
loss function
we don't want to make a jump so large
that we skip over the optimal value for
a given weight
to make sure this doesn't happen we use
a variable called the learning rate
this thing is usually just a small
number like 0.001
that we multiply the gradients by to
scale them this ensures that any changes
we make to our weights are pretty small
in math talk taking steps that are too
large can mean that the algorithm will
never converge to an optimum
at the same time we don't want to take
steps that are too small
because then we might never end up with
the right values for our weights
in math talk steps that are too small
might lead to our optimizer converging
on a local minimum
for the loss function but never the
absolute minimum
for a simple summary just remember that
the learning rate ensures that we change
our weight at the right pace
not making any changes that are too big
or too small
instead of calculating the gradients for
all your training examples on
every part of the gradient descent it's
sometimes more efficient to only use a
subset
of the training examples each time
stochastic gradient descent is an
implementation that either uses batches
of examples at a time
or random examples on each pass
stochastic gradient descent uses the
concept of momentum
momentum accumulates gradients of the
past steps to dictate what might happen
in the next steps
also because we don't include the entire
training set
sjd is less computationally expensive
it's difficult to overstate how popular
gradient descent really is
back propagation is basically gradient
descent implemented on a network
there are other types of optimizers
based on gradient descent that are used
today
ad grad adapts the learning rate
specifically to individual features
that means that some of the weights in
your data set will have different
learning rates than others
this works really well for sparse data
sets where a lot of input
examples are missing at a grad has a
major issue though
the adaptive learning rate tends to get
really really small over time
rms prop is a special version of adegrad
developed by professor jeffrey hinton
instead of letting all the gradients
accumulate for momentum
it accumulates gradients in a fixed
window
rms prop is similar to add a prop which
is another optimizer that seeks to solve
some of the issues that atograd leaves
open
atom stands for adaptive moment
estimation and is another way of using
past gradients to calculate the carbon
gradient
atom also utilizes the concept of
momentum which is basically our way of
telling the neural network
whether we want past changes to affect
the new change by adding fractions of
the previous gradients to the current
one
this optimizer has become pretty
widespread and is practically accepted
for use in training new networks
it's easy to get lost in the complexity
of some of these new optimizers
just remember that they all have the
same goal minimizing the loss function
and trial and error will get you there
you may have heard me referring to the
words parameters quite a bit
and often this word is confused with the
term hyperparameters
in this video i'm going to outline the
basic difference between the two
a model parameter is a variable that is
internal to the new network
and whose values can be estimated from
the data itself
they are required by the model when
making predictions
these values define the skill of the
model on your problem
they can be estimated directly from the
data and are often not manually set by
the practitioner
and oftentimes when you save your model
you are essentially
saving your model's parameters
parameters are key to machine learning
algorithms and examples of these
include the weights and the biases
a hyper parameter is a configuration
that is external to the model
and whose value cannot be estimated from
data there's no way that we can find the
best value for a model hyper parameter
on a given problem
we may use rules of thumb copy values
used in other problems
or search for the best value by trial
and error
when a machine learning algorithm is
tuned for a specific problem such as
when you're using grid search or random
search
then you are in fact tuning the hyper
parameters of the model
in order to discover the parameters that
result in more skillful predictions
model hyper parameters are often
referred to as parameters which can make
things confusing
so a good rule of thumb to overcome this
confusion is as follows
if you have to specify a parameter
manually
then it is probably a hyper parameter
parameters are inherent to the model
itself
some examples of hyper parameters
include the learning rate for training
on your network
the c in sigma hyper parameters for
sport vector machines
and the k and k newest neighbors
we need terminologies like epochs batch
size and iterations
only when the data is too big which
happens all the time in machine learning
and when we can't pass all this data to
the computer at once
so to overcome this problem we need to
divide the data set into smaller chunks
give it to our computer one by one and
update the weights of the new network at
the end of every step
to fit it into the data given one epoch
is when an entire data set is passed
forward and backward through the network
once in a majority of deep learning
models we use
more than one epoch i know it does make
sense in the beginning why do we need to
pass the entire data set many times
through the same neural network passing
the entire data set through the network
only once
is trying to read the entire lyrics of a
song once
he won't be able to remember the entire
song immediately you have to reread the
lyrics a couple more times before you
can say you know the song by memory
the same is true with the neural network
we pass the data set
multiple times through the neural
network so it's able to generalize
better gradient descent is an iterative
process and updating the parameters and
back propagation in a single
pass or one epoch is not enough as the
number of epochs increases
the more the parameters are adjusted
leading to a better performing model
but too many epochs could spell disaster
and lead to something called overfitting
where a model has essentially memorized
the patterns in the training data
and performs terribly on data it's never
seen before
so what is the right number of epochs
unfortunately there is no right answer
the answer is different for different
data sets sometimes your data set can
include
millions of examples passing this entire
data set at once
becomes extremely difficult so what we
do instead
is divide the data set into a number of
batches
rather than passing the entire dataset
once the total number of training
examples present in a single batch
is called a batch size iterations is the
number of batches needed to complete one
epoch
note the number of batches is equal to
the number of
iterations for one epoch let's say that
we have a data set of 34 000 training
examples
if we divide the data set into batches
of 500
then it will take 68 iterations to
complete one epoch
well i hope that gives you some kind of
sense about the very basic
terminologies used in deep learning
before we move on i do want to mention
this
and you will see this a lot in deep
learning you'll often have a bunch of
different
choices to make how many hidden layers
should i choose or which activation
function must i use and where
and to be honest there are no clear-cut
guidelines as to what your choice should
always be
that's a fun part about deep learning
it's extremely difficult
to know in the beginning what's the
right combination to use for your
project
what works for me might not work for you
and a suggestion from my end would be
that you dabble along with material
shown
try various combinations and see what
works for you best
ultimately that's a learning process pun
intended
throughout this course i'll give you
quite a bit of intuition as to what's
popular
so that when it comes to building a deep
learning project you won't find yourself
lost
in this section we're going to talk
about the different types of learning
which are machine learning concepts but
i extended to deep learning as well
in this course we'll go over supervised
learning unsupervised learning
and reinforcement learning
supervised learning is the most common
sub branch machine learning today
typically if you're new to machine
learning your journey will begin with
supervised learning algorithms
let's explore what these are supervised
machine learning algorithms are designed
to learn by example
the name supervised learning originates
from the idea that training this type of
algorithm
is almost like there's a human
supervising the whole process
in supervised learning we train our
models on well-labeled data
each example is a pair consisting of an
input object
which is typically a vector and a
desired output value
also called a supervisory signal during
training
a supervised learning algorithm will
search for patterns in the data
that correlate with the desired outputs
after training
it will take in new unseen inputs and
will determine which label the new
inputs will be classified as
based on prior training data the
objective of a supervised learning model
is to predict the correct label for
newly presented input data
at its most basic form a supervised
learning algorithm can simply be written
as y is equal
f x where y is the predicted output that
is determined by a mapping function
that assigns a class to an input value x
the function used to connect
input features to a predicted output is
created by the machine learning model
during training supervised learning can
be split into two subcategories
classification and regression during
training a classification algorithm will
be given data points with an assigned
category
the job of a classification algorithm is
then to take this input value
and assigned to a class of category that
it fits into
based on the training data provided the
most common example of classification
is determining if an email is spam or
not
with two classes to choose from spam or
not spam
this problem is called a binary
classification problem
the algorithm will be given training
data with emails that are both spam and
not spam
and the model will find the features
within the data that correlate to either
class
and create a mapping function
then when provided with an unseen email
the model will use this function to
determine whether or not the email is
pam
an example of a classification problem
would be the mnist handwritten digits
dataset
where the inputs are images of
handwritten digits pixel data
and the output is the class label for
what digit the image represents
that is numbers zero to nine there are
numerous algorithms to solve
classification problems each which
depends on the data
and the situation here are a few popular
classification algorithms
linear classifiers support vector
machines decision trees
k-nearest neighbors and drellum forest
regression is a predictive statistical
process
where the model attempts to find the
important relationship
between dependent and independent
variables
the goal of a regression algorithm is to
predict a continuous number
such as sales income and tax scores
the equation for a basic linear
regression can be written as follows
where x and 5 represents the features of
the data and w of i
and b are parameters which are developed
during training
for simple linear regression models with
only one feature in the data
the formula looks like this where w is
the slope
x is the single feature and b is a
y-intercept
familiar for simple regression problems
such as this the model's predictions are
represented by the line of best fit
for models using two features a plane is
used and for models with more than two
features
a hyperplane is used imagine we want to
determine a student's test grade
based on how many hours they study the
week of the test
let's say the plot data with line of
best fit looks like this
there is a clear positive correlation
between our studied
the independent variable and the
student's final test goals the dependent
variable
a line of best fit can be drawn through
the data points to show the model's
predictions
when given new input say we wanted to
know how well a student would do with
five hours of study
we can use the line of best fit to
predict the test call
based on other students performances
another example of regression problem
would be the boston house prices data
set
where the input of variables that
describe a neighborhood and the output
is a house price in dollars
there are many different types of
regression algorithms three most common
are linear regression lasso regression
and multivariate regression
supervised learning finds applications
in classification and regression
problems like
bioinformatics such as fingerprint iris
and face recognition in smartphones
object recognition spam detection and
speech recognition
unsupervised learning is a branch of
machine learning that is used to
manifest
underlying patterns and data and is
often used in exploratory data analysis
unlike supervised learning unsupervised
learning does not use label data
but instead focuses on the data's
features
label training data has a corresponding
output for each input
the goal of an unsupervised learning
algorithm is to analyze data
and find important features in that data
unsupervised learning will often find
subgroups or hidden patterns within the
dataset that a human observer might not
pick up on
and this is extremely useful as we'll
soon find out
unsupervised learning can be of two
types clustering and association
clustering is the simplest and among the
most common applications of unsupervised
learning
it is the process of grouping the given
data into different clusters or groups
classes will contain data points that
are as similar as possible to each other
and as dissimilar as possible to data
points in other clusters
clustering helps find underlying
patterns within the data
that may not be noticeable through a
human observer
it can be broken down into partitional
clustering and hierarchical clustering
partitional clustering refers to a set
of clustering algorithms where each data
point in a data set
can belong to only one cluster
hierarchical clustering finds clusters
by a system of hierarchies
every data point can belong to multiple
clusters some classes will contain
smaller clusters within it
this hierarchy system can be organized
as a tree diagram
some of the more commonly used
clustering algorithms are the k-means
expectation and the hierarchical cluster
analysis of the aca
association on the other hand attempts
to find relationships between different
entities
the classic example of association rules
is
market basket analysis this means
using a database of transactions in the
supermarket
to find items that are frequently bought
together for example a person who buys
potatoes and burgers
usually buys beer for example the person
who buys tomatoes and pizza cheese
might want to bring pizza bread and so
on
unsupervised learning finds applications
almost everywhere
for example airbnb which helps host
stays and experiences
and connect people all over the world
this application uses unsupervised
learning algorithms where a potential
client
queries their requirements and airbnb
learns these patterns and recommends
stays and experiences
which fall under the same group of
cluster example a person looking for
houses in san francisco
might not be interested in finding
houses in boston amazon also uses
unsupervised learning to learn the
customers purchases
and recommend products which are
frequently bought together
which is an example of association rule
mining
credit card fraud detection is another
unsupervised learning algorithm
that learns the various patterns of a
user and and their usage of a credit
card
if the card is used in parts that do not
match the behavior
an alarm is generated which could
possibly be marked as fraud
and in some cases your bank might call
you to confirm whether it was you using
the card or not
reinforcement learning is a type of
machine learning technique that enables
an
agent to learn in an interactive
environment by trial and error
using feedback from its own actions and
experiences
like supervised learning it uses mapping
between the input
and the output but unlike supervised
learning where feedback provided to the
agent is a correct set of actions for
performing a task
reinforcement learning uses rewards and
punishments
as signals for positive and negative
behavior
when you compare with unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning is
different in terms of its goals
while the goal in unsupervised learning
is to find similarities and differences
between data points
in reinforcement learning the goal is to
find a suitable action model
that would maximize the total cumulative
reward of the agent
reinforcement learning refers to
goal-oriented algorithms
which learn how to attain a complex
objective or goal
or how to maximize along a particular
dimension over many steps
for example they can maximize the points
of one in a game over many moves
reinforcement learning algorithms can
start from a blank slate
and under the right conditions achieve
superhuman performance
like a pet incentivized by scolding and
treats
these algorithms are penalized when they
make the wrong decisions
and rewarded when they make the right
ones this is reinforcement
reinforcement learning is usually
modeled as a markov decision process
although
other frameworks like queue learning are
used
some key terms that describe the
elements of a reinforcement learning
problem
are the environment which is the
physical world in which the agent
operates
the state represents the current
situation of the agent
reward is a feedback received from the
environment
policy sometimes is the method to map
the agent state to the agent's actions
and finally
value is the future reward that an agent
will receive
by taking an action in a particular
state
a reinforcement learning problem can be
best explained through games
let's take the game of pac-man where the
goal of the agent
or pac-man is to eat the food in the
grid while avoiding the ghosts on its
way
the grid world is the interactive
environment for the agent
pac-man receives a reward for eating
food and punishment if it gets killed by
the ghost
that is it loses the game the states are
the location of pac-man in the grid
world
and the total cumulative reward is
pac-man winning the game
reinforcement learning finds
applications in robotics
business strategy planning traffic light
control
web system configuration and aircraft
and robot motion control
a central problem in deep learning is
how to make an algorithm that will
perform well
not just in training data but also on
new inputs
one of the most common challenges you'll
face when training models
is a problem of overfitting a situation
where your model performs exceptionally
well on training data
but not in testing data see i have a
data set graphed on the xy plane like so
now i want to construct a model that
would best fit the data set
what i could do is draw a line of some
random slope in intercept
now evidently this isn't the best model
and in fact this is called
underfitting because it doesn't fit the
model well in fact it underestimates the
data set
instead what we could do is draw a line
that looks something like this
now this really fits our model the best
but
this is overfitting remember that while
training
we show our networks and training data
and once that's done
we'd expect it to be almost close to
perfect
the problem with this graph is that
although it is probably the best line of
fit for this graph
it is the best line of fit only if
you're considering your trading data
what your network is done in this graph
is memorize the patterns between the
trading data
and won't give accurate predictions at
all on data it's never seen before
and this makes sense because instead of
memorizing patterns generally
to perform well on both training as well
as new testing data
our network in fact has memorized the
patterns only on the training data
so it obviously won't perform well on
new data it's never seen before
this is the problem of overfitting it
fitted
too much and by the way this would be
the more accurate kind of fitting
it's not perfect but it'll do well on
both training as well as new testing
data
with sizeable accuracy there are a
couple of ways to tackle overfitting
the most interesting type of
regularization is dropout
it produces very good results and is
consequently the most frequently used
regularization technique in the field of
deep learning
to understand dropout let's say that we
have a new network with two hidden
layers
what dropout does is that at every
iteration it randomly selects some nodes
and removes them along with their
incoming and outgoing connections
as shown so each iteration has a
different set of nodes
and this results in a different set of
outputs
so why do these models perform better
these models usually perform better than
a single model
as they capture more randomness and
memorizes less of the training data
and hence will be folks to generalize
better and build a more robust
predictive model
sometimes the best way to make a deep
learning model generalized better
is to train it on mode data in practice
the amount of data we have is limited
and one way to get around this problem
is to create fake data
and add it to the training set for some
deep learning tasks
it is reasonably straightforward to
create new fake data
this approach is easiest for
classification a classifier needs to
take
complicated high dimensional input x and
summarize it with the category
identity y this means that the main task
facing a classifier
is to be invariant to a wide variety of
transformations
we can generate new xy pairs easily just
by applying transformations on the xy
inputs in our training set dataset
augmentation has been a particularly
effective technique for a specific
classification problem
object recognition images are high
dimensional and
include an enormous range of factors of
variation
many of which can easily be simulated
operations like translating the training
images a few pixels in each direction
can often greatly improve generalization
many other operations such as rotating
the image or scaling the image
have also proved quite effective you
must be careful not to apply
transformation that would change the
correct class
for example in optical character
recognition
tasks that require recognizing the
difference between a b
and a d and the difference between a six
and a nine
horizontal flips and 180 degree
rotations are not appropriate ways of
augmenting data sets with these tasks
when training large models with
sufficient representational capacity to
overfit the task
we often observe that the training error
decreases steadily over time
but the error validation set begins to
rise again
this means we can obtain a model with
better validation set error
and thus hopefully better test that
error by stopping training at the point
where the error in the validation set
starts to increase this strategy is
known as early stopping
it is probably the most commonly used
form of regularization in deploying
today
its popularity is due to both its
effectiveness and its simplicity
in this section i'm going to introduce
the three most common types of neural
network architectures today
fully connected v4 with new networks
recurring neural networks
and convolutional neural networks
the first type of new network
architecture we're going to discuss
is a fully connected feed forward neural
network by fully connected i mean that
each neuron in the preceding layer
is connected to every neuron in the
subsequent layer
without any connection backwards there
are no cycles or loops in the
connections in the network
as i mentioned previously each neuron in
a neural network contains an activation
function
that changes the output of a neuron when
given its input
there are several types of activation
functions that can change this input to
output relationship
to make a neuron behave in a variety of
ways
some of the most well-known activation
functions are the linear function
which is a straight line that
essentially multiplies the input by a
constant value
the sigmoid function that ranges from
zero to one the hyperbolic tangent of
the tanning function
ranges from negative one to positive one
and the rectified linear unit
or the relu function which is a
piecewise function that outputs a zero
if the input is less than a certain
value
or a linear multiple if the input is
greater than a certain value
each type of activation function has its
pros and cons so we use them in various
layers in the deep neural network
based on the problem each is designed to
solve in addition the last three
activation functions we refer to as
non-linear functions
because the output is not a linear
multiple of the input
non-linearity is what allows deep neural
networks to model
complex functions using everything we've
learned so far
we can create a wide variety of fully
connected feed for neural networks
we can create networks with various
inputs various
outputs various hidden layers neurons
per hidden layer and a variety of
activation functions
these numerous combinations allow us to
create a variety of powerful
deep neural networks that can solve the
wide array of problems
the more neurons we add to each hidden
layer the wider the network becomes
in addition the more hidden layers we
add the deeper the network becomes
however each neuron we add increases the
complexity
and thus the computational resource
necessary to train a new network
increases this increasing complexity
isn't linear in the number of neurons we
add so it leads to an explosion in
complexity and training time
for large neural networks that's the
trade-off you need to consider
when you are building deep neural
networks
all the new networks we've discussed so
far are known as feed forward neural
networks
they take in a fixed sized input and
give you a fixed size output that's all
it does
and that's what we expect neural
networks to do take in an input and give
a sizeable output
but as it turns out these plane of
vanilla neural networks
aren't able to model every single
problem that we have today
to better understand this use this
analogy suppose i show you the picture
of a ball
a round spherical ball that was moving
in space in some direction
i've just taken a photo of the ball or a
snapshot of the ball at some time t
now i want you to predict the next
position of the ball in say two or three
seconds
you're probably not going to give me an
accurate answer now
let's look at another example suppose i
walk up to you and say the word
dog you will never understand my
statement because
well it doesn't make sense there are
trilling combinations solely using the
word dog
and among these trillion combinations
i'm expecting you to now guess
what i'm trying to tell you what these
two examples have in common
is that it doesn't make sense it doesn't
in the first case i'm expecting you to
predict the next position in time
and in the second i'm expecting you to
understand what i mean by dog
these two examples cannot be understood
and interpreted
unless some information about the pass
was supplied
now in the first example if i give you
the previous position states of the ball
and now ask you to predict the future
trajectory of the ball
you're going to be able to do this
accurately and in the second case if i
give you a full sentence saying
i have a dog this makes sense because
now you understand that out of the
trillion possible combinations involving
a dog my original intent was for you to
understand that i have a dog
why did i give you this example how does
this apply to neural networks
in the introduction i said vanilla
neural networks can't model every single
situation or problem that we have
and the biggest problem it turns out is
that plain vanilla feed forward neural
networks cannot
model sequential data sequential data
is data in a sequence for example a
sentence is a sequence of what
a ball moving in space is a sequence of
all its position states
in the sentence that i've shown you you
understood each word
based off your understanding of the
previous words this is called sequential
memory
you were able to understand the data
point in the sequence by your memory of
the previous data point in that sequence
traditional neural networks can't do
this and it seems like a major
shortcoming
one of the disadvantages of modelling
sequences with traditional neural
networks
is the fact that they don't share
parameters across time
let us take for example these two
sentences on tuesday it was raining and
it was raining on tuesday
these sentences mean the same thing
although the details are in different
parts of the sequence
actually when we feed these sentences
into a field for new network for a
prediction task
the model will assign different weights
to on tuesday
and it was raining at each moment in
time
things we learn about the sequence won't
transfer if they appear at different
points in the sequence
sharing parameters gives the network the
ability to look for a given feature
everywhere in the sequence rather than
just in a certain area
that's the model sequences we need a
specific learning framework
able to deal with variable lens
sequences maintain sequence order
and to keep track of long-term
dependencies rather than cutting
input data too short and finally to
share parameters across the sequence
so as to not reload things
and that's where recurrent neural
networks come in
rnns are a type of new network
architecture that use something called a
feedback
loop in the hidden layer unlike feed
forward new networks
the recurrent neural network or rnn can
operate effectively on sequences of data
with variable input length this is how
an rnn is usually represented
this little loop here is called the
feedback loop
sometimes you may find the rnns depicted
over time like this
the first path represents the network in
the first time step
the hidden node h1 uses the input x1 to
produce
output y1 this is exactly what we've
seen with basic feed forward new
networks
however at the second time step the
hidden node at the current time step
h2 uses both the new input x2
as well as the state from the previous
time step h1
as input to make new predictions
this means that a current neural network
uses knowledge of its previous states as
input for its current prediction and we
can repeat this process for an arbitrary
number of steps
allowing for the network to propagate
information by its hidden state
throughout time
this is almost like giving a neural
network a short-term memory
they have this abstract concept of
sequential memory and because of this
we're able to model certain areas of
data sequential data
that standalone neural networks aren't
able to model
recurrent neural networks remember their
past and their decisions are influenced
by
what it has learned from the past basic
feed-forward networks remember things
too
but they remember things they learned
during training for example an image
classifier learns what a three looks
like during training
and then uses that knowledge to classify
things in production
so how do we train an rnn well it is
almost the same as
training a basic fully connected feed
forward network
except that the back propagation
algorithm is applied for every sequence
data point
rather than the entire sequence this
algorithm is sometimes called the back
propagation through time
algorithm or the btt algorithm
to really understand how this works
imagine we're creating a recurring new
network to predict the next letter a
person is likely to type
based on the previous letters they've
already typed
the letter that a user just typed is
quite important to predicting the new
letter
however all the previous letters are
also very important
to this prediction as well at the first
time step
say the user typed the letter f so a
network might predict that the next
letter is in e
based on all of the previous training
examples that included the word
fe at the next time step the user types
the letter r
so our network uses both the new letter
r plus the state of the first hidden
neuron
in order to compute the next prediction
l
the network predicts this because of the
high frequency of occurrences in the
word fel
in our training data set adding the
letter a
might predict the letter t adding an n
would predict the letter k
which would match the word i use in
tender to type
which is frank there however is an issue
with rnn's
known as short-term memory short-term
memory is caused by the infamous
vanishing and exploding gradient
problems as the rnn processes more words
it has trouble retaining information
from previous steps
kind of like our memory if you're given
a long sequence of numbers like pi
and you tried reading them out you're
probably going to forget the initial few
digits right
short-term memory and the vanishing
gradient is due to the nature of back
propagation
the algorithm used to train and optimize
neural networks
after the forward propagation or the
pass the network compares this
prediction
to the ground truth using a loss
function which outputs an error value
an estimate of how poorly the network is
performing
the network uses that error value to
perform back propagation
which calculates the gradients for each
node in the network the gradient is the
value used to adjust the network's
internal weights
allowing for the network to learn the
bigger the gradient the bigger the
adjustments are
and vice versa here's where the problem
lies
when performing back propagation each
node in a layer
calculates its gradient with respect to
the effects of the gradient in the layer
before it
so if the adjustment to the layers
before it is small
then the adjustments to the current
layer will be even smaller
and this causes gradients to
exponentially shrink as it back
propagates down
the earlier layers fail to do any
learning as the internal weights are
barely being adjusted due to extremely
small
gradients and that is the vanishing
gradient problem
let's see how this applies to recover
new networks you can think of each time
step in a recurrent neural network as a
layer
to train recon neural network you use an
application of back propagation
called back propagation through time the
gradient values will exponentially
shrink as the back propagates through
each time step
again the gradient is used to make
adjustments in the new network weights
thus allowing it to learn small
gradients means small adjustments
and this causes the early layers not
alone
because of the vanishing gradient the
rnn doesn't learn the long range
dependencies across time steps
this means that in a sequence it was
raining on tuesday
there is a possibility that the words it
and was are not considered
when trying to predict the user's
intention
the network then has to make the best
guess with on tuesday
and that's pretty ambiguous and would be
difficult even for a human
so not being able to learn on earlier
time steps causes the network to have a
short-term memory
we can combat the short-term memory of
an rnn by using two variants of
recurrent neural networks
gated rnns and long short-term memory
rnns
also known as lcms both these variants
function just like rns but they're
capable of learning
long-term dependencies using mechanisms
called gates
these gates are different tensor
operations that learn
information that can learn what
information to add or remove to the
hidden state
or the feedback loop the main difference
between a gated rnn
and an lscm is that the gated rnn has
two gates to control its memory an
update gate and reset gate while an lsem
has three gates an input gate an output
gate
and a forget gate rnns work well for
applications that
involve sequences of data that change
over time
these applications include natural
language processing
sentiment classification dna sequence
classification
speech recognition and language
translation
a convolutional neural network or cnn
for short
is a type of deep neural network
architecture designed for specific tasks
like
image classification cnns were inspired
by the organization of neurons
in the visual cortex of the animal brain
as a result
they provide some very interesting
features that are useful for processing
certain types of data like images audio
and video like a fully connected neural
network
a cnn is composed of an input layer an
output layer
and several hidden layers between the
two cnns derive their names from the
type of hidden layers it consists of
the hidden layers of a cnn typically
consist of convolutional layers
pooling layers fully connected layers
and normalization layers
this means that instead of traditional
activation functions we use in
feed-forward neural networks
convolution and pooling functions are
used instead more often than not the
input of a cnn is typically a
two-dimensional array of neurons
which correspond to the pixels of an
image for example if you're doing
image classification the output layer is
typically one-dimensional
convolution is a technique that allows
us to extract
visual features from a 2d array in small
chunks
each neuron in a convolution layer is
responsible for a small cluster of
neurons in the preceding layer
the bounding box that determines the
cluster of neurons is called a filter
also called a kernel conceptually you
can think of it as a filter moving
across an image
and performing a mathematical operation
on individual regions of the image
it then sends its result to the
corresponding neuron in the convolution
layer
mathematically a convolution of two
functions f and g
is defined as follows which is in fact
the dot product of the input function
and the kernel function
pooling also known as sub sampling or
down sampling
is the next step in a convolutional
neural network
its objective is to further reduce the
number of neurons necessary
in subsequent layers of the network
while still retaining the most important
information
there are two different types of pooling
that can be performed max pulling and
min pooling
as the name suggests max pooling is
based on picking up the maximum value
from the selected region
and min pooling is based on picking up
the minimum value
from that region when we put all these
techniques together
we get an architecture for a deep neural
network quite different from a fully
connected neural network for image
classification where cnns are used
heavily
we first take an input image which is a
two-dimensional matrix of pixels
typically with three color channels red
green and blue
next we use a convolution layer with
multiple filters
to create a two-dimensional feature
matrix as the output for each filter
we then pool the results to produce a
downsample feature matrix
for each filter in the convolution layer
next we typically repeat the convolution
and pooling steps multiple times
using previous features as input then we
add a few fully connected hidden layers
to help classify the image
and finally we produce a classification
prediction
in the output layer convolutional neural
networks
are used heavily in the field of
computer vision and work well for a
variety of tasks including
image recognition image processing image
segmentation
video analysis and natural language
processing
in this section i'm going to discuss the
5 steps that are common in every deep
learning project that you build
these can be extended to include various
other aspects
but at its very core they are very
fundamentally five steps
data is at the core of what deep
learning is all about
your model will only be as powerful as
the data you bring
which brings me to the first step
gathering your data
the choice of data and how much data you
would require
entirely depends on the problem you're
trying to solve picking the right data
is key and i can't stress how important
this part is
bad data implies a bad model
a good rule of thumb is to make
assumptions about the data you require
and be careful to record these
assumptions so that you can test
them later if needed data comes in a
variety of sizes
for example iris flaw data set contains
about 150 images in the total set
gmail smart reply has around 238 million
examples in its running sets
and google translate reportedly has
trillions of data points
when you're choosing a data set there's
no one-size-fits-all
but the general rule of thumb is that
the amount of data you need for a
well-performing model
should be 10 times the number of
parameters in that model
however this may differ from time to
time depending on the type of model
you're building
for example in regression analysis you
should use
around 10 examples per predictor
variable for image classification
the minimum you should have is around a
thousand images per class that you're
trying to classify
while quantity of data matters quality
matters too
there's no use having a lot of data if
it's bad data
there are certain aspects of quality
that tend to correspond to
well-performing models
one aspect is reliability reliability
refers to the degree in which you can
trust your data
a model train on a reliable data set is
more likely to yield useful predictions
than model trained on unreliable data
how common are label errors if your data
is labeled by humans
sometimes there may be mistakes are your
features noisy
is it completely accurate some noise is
all right you'll never be able to purge
your data of all the noise
there are many other factors that
determine quality for the purpose of
this video though
i'm not going to talk about the
remaining although if you're interested
i'll leave them in the show notes below
lucky for us there are plenty of
resources on the web that offer good
data sets for free
here are a few sites where you can begin
your dataset search the uci machine
learning repository
maintains around 500 extremely well
maintained data sets
that you can use in your deep learning
projects kaggle's another one
you'll love how detailed that data sets
are they give you info on the features
data types number of records and so on
you can use a kernel too and you won't
have to download the data set
google's dataset search is still in beta
but is one of the most amazing sites
that you can find today
reddit2 is a great place to request for
data sets you want
but again there is a chance of not being
properly organized
create your own data set that will work
too you can use web scrapers like
beautiful soup
to get your required data for the data
set
after you have selected your data set
you now need to think of how you're
going to use this data
there are some common pre-processing
steps that you should follow
first splitting the data set into
subsets
in general we usually split a data set
into three parts
training testing and validating sets we
train our modules with the training set
evaluated on the validation set and
finally
once it's ready to use test it one last
time on the testing data set
now it is reasonable to ask the
following question why not have two sets
training and testing in that way the
process will be much simpler
just train the model on the training
data and test it on the testing data
the answer to that is developing a model
involves tuning its configuration
in other words choosing certain values
for the hyper parameters or the weight
and biases
this tuning is done with the feedback
received from the validation set and
is in essence a form of learning it
turns out we just can't split the data
set randomly
do that and you'll get random results
there has to be some kind of logic to
split the data set
essentially what you want is for all
three sets the training
testing and validation sets to be very
similar to each other
and to eliminate skewing as much as
possible
this mainly depends on two things first
the total number of samples in your data
and second or the actual model you're
trying to train
models with very few hyper parameters
will be very easy to validate in tune
so you can probably reduce the size of
your validation set
but if your model has many hyper
parameters you would want to have a
large validation set
as well as consider cross validation
also if you happen to have a model with
no hyper parameters whatsoever
or ones that cannot be easily tuned you
probably don't need a validation set
all in all like many other things in
machine learning and deep learning
the train test validation split ratio is
also quite specific to your use case
and it gets easier to make judgment as
you train and build more and more models
so
here's a quick note on cross validation
usually you'd want to split your data
set into two
the train and the test after this you
keep aside the test set
and randomly choose some percentage of
the training
set to be the actual train set and the
remaining
to be the validation set the model is
then
iteratively trained and validated on
these different sets
there are multiple ways to do this and
this is commonly known
as cross validation basically you use
your training set
to generate multiple splits of the train
and validation set
cross validation avoids overfitting and
is getting more and more popular
with k fold cross validation being the
most popular method
additionally if you're working on time
series data a frequent technique is to
split the data by time
for example if you have a dataset with
40 days of data
you can train your data from days 1 to
39 and evaluate your model
on the data from day 40.
for systems like this the training data
is older than the serving data
so this technique ensures your
validation set mirrors the lag
between training and serving however
keep in mind that time-based splits
work best with very very large data sets
such as those with tens of millions of
examples
the second method that we have in
pre-processing is formatting the data
set that you've picked might not be in
the right format that you like
for example the data might be in the
form of a database
but you'd like it as a csv file vice
versa
of course there are a couple of ways to
do this and you can google them if
you'd like dealing with missing data is
one of the most challenging steps in the
gathering of data
for your deep learning projects unless
you're extremely lucky to land with the
perfect data set
which is quite rare dealing with missing
data will probably take a significant
chunk of your time
it is quite common in real world
problems to miss some values of our data
samples
this may be due to errors on the data
collection blank spaces on surveys
measurements not applicable and so on
missing values are typically represented
with the nan or the null indicators
the problem with this is that most
algorithms can't handle these kind of
missing values
so we need to take care of them before
feeding data to our models
there are a couple of ways to deal with
them one is eliminating the samples of
the features with missing values
the downside of code is that you risk to
delete relevant information
the second step is to impute the missing
values
a common way is to set the missing
values as the mean value for the rest of
the samples
but of course there are other ways to
deal with specific data sets
be smart as handling missing data in the
wrong way can spell disasters
sometimes you may have too much data
that what you require
more data can result in larger
computational and memory requirements
in cases like this it's best practice to
use a small sample of the data set
it will be faster and ultimately an
increase in time for you to explore and
prototype solutions
in most real world data sets you're
going to come across imbalanced data
that is classification data that has
skewed class proportions
leading to the rise of a minority class
and a majority class if we train a model
on data like this
a model will only spend time learning
about the majority class
and a lot less time on the minority
class
and hence a model will ultimately be
biased to the majority class and so in
cases like this
we usually use a process called down
sampling and
up weighting which is essentially
reducing majority cost by some factor
and adding example weights of that
factor to the down sample class
for example if we down sample the
majority cost by a factor of 10
then the example weighted we add to that
class should be 10.
it may seem odd to add example weights
after down sampling
what is its purpose well there are a
couple of reasons
at least a faster convergence during
training we see the minority class more
often
which helps the model converge faster by
consolidating the majority class into
fewer examples with larger weights
we spend less disk space storing them
operating ensures their model is still
calibrated we add operating
after down sampling so as to keep the
data set
in similar proportion these processes
essentially help a model
see more of the minority costs rather
than just solely the majority class
this helps our model perform better in
real world situations
feature scaling is a crucial step in the
pre-processing phase
as the majority of deep learning
algorithms perform much
better when dealing with features that
are on the same scale
the most common techniques are
normalization which refers to the
rescaling of features
to a range between 0 and 1 which in fact
is a special case of min max scaling
to normalize that data we need to apply
min max scaling to each
feature column standardization consists
of centering the field at mean 0 with
standard deviation 1
so that the feature columns have the
same parameters as a standard normal
distribution
that is 0 mean and unit variance
this makes it much easier for the
learning algorithms to learn the weights
of the parameters
in addition it keeps useful information
about outliers
and makes the algorithms less sensitive
to them
once our data has been prepared we now
feed this into our network to trade
we've discussed the learning process of
a neural network in the previous module
so if you are unsure i'd advise you to
watch that module first
but essentially once a data has been fed
forward propagation occurs
and the losses compared against the loss
function and the parameters are adjusted
based on this loss incurred
again nothing too different from what we
discussed previously
your model has successfully trained
congratulations
now we need to test how good our model
is using the validation set that we had
set aside earlier
the evaluation process allows us to test
a model against data
it has never seen before and this is
meant to be representative
of how good the model might perform in
the real world
after the evaluation process there's a
high chance that your model could be
optimized further
remember we started with random weights
and biases and these were fine-tuned
during back propagation
well in quite a few cases bad
propagation won't get it right the first
time
and that's okay there are a few ways to
optimize your model further
tuning hyper parameters is a good way of
optimizing your model's performance
one way to do this is by showing the
model the entire data set multiple times
that is by increasing the number of
epochs
this has sometimes shown to improve
accuracy in other ways by adjusting the
learning rate
we talked about what the learning rate
was in the previous module so if you
don't know what the learning rate is i
do advise you to check out the previous
module
but essentially the learning rate
defines how far we shift the line during
each step
based on information from the previous
training step in back propagation
these values all play a role in how
accurate a model can become
and how long the training takes for
complex models
initial conditions can play a
significant role in determining the
outcome of training
there are many considerations at this
phase of training and it's important you
define
what makes a model good enough otherwise
you might find yourself tweaking
parameters for a long
long time the adjustment of these hyper
parameters
remains a bit of an art and is more of
an experimental process that heavily
depends on the specifics of your data
set
model and training process you will
develop this as you go more and more
into deep learning
so don't worry too much about this now
one of the more common problems you will
encounter is when your model performs
well on training data but performs
terribly on data it's never seen before
this is the problem of overfitting this
happens when the model learns a pattern
specific to the training data set
that aren't relevant to other unseen
data
there are two ways to avoid this
overfitting getting more data
and regularization getting more data is
usually the best solution
a model trainer mode data will naturally
generalize better
reducing the model size by reducing the
number of learnable parameters in the
model
and with it its learning capacity is
another way
however by lowering the capacity of the
network you force it to learn
patterns that matter or then minimize
the loss
on the other hand reducing the network's
capacity too much
will lead to underfitting the model will
not be able to learn the relevant
patterns in the trained data
unfortunately there are no magical
formulas to determine this balance
it must be tested and evaluated by
setting different number of parameters
and observing its performance the second
method to addressing overfitting is by
applying weight
regularization to the model a common way
to achieve this is to constraint the
complexity of the network
by forcing its weights to take only
small values
regularizing the distribution of weight
values
this is done by adding to the loss
function of the network a cost
associated with having larger weights
and this cost comes in two ways
l1 regularization at the cost with
regards to the
absolute value of the weight coefficient
or the l1 norm of the weights l2
regularization
adds a cost with regards to the squared
value of the weight's coefficient
that is the l2 norm of the weight
another way of reducing overfitting is
by augmenting data
for a model to perform well or
satisfactory we need to have a lot of
data
we've just have just already but
typically if you're working with images
there's always a chance that your model
won't perform as well as you'd like it
no matter how much data you have in
cases like this when you have
limited data sets data augmentation is a
good way of increasing your data set
without really increasing it we
artificially augment our data or in this
case images
so that we get more data from already
existing data
so what kind of augmentations are we
talking about well
anything from flipping the image of the
y-axis flipping over the x-axis
applying blur to even zooming on in the
image
what this does is that it shows your
model more than what meets the eye
it exposes your model to more of the
existing data
so that in testing it will automatically
perform better
because it has seen images represented
in almost every single form
finally the last method we're going to
talk about is dropout
dropout is a technique used in deep
learning that randomly drops out units
or neurons in the network simply put
dropout refers to the ignoring of
neurons during the training phase
of a randomly chosen set of neurons by
ignoring
i mean that these units are not
considered during a particular forward
or backward pass
so why do we need dropout at all why do
we need to shut down parts of a neural
network
a fully connected layer occupies most of
the parameters
and hence neurons develop a
co-dependency amongst each other during
training
which curbs the individual power of each
neuron and which ultimately leads to
overfitting of the training data
so drop out a good way of reducing
overfitting
i hope that this introductory course has
helped you develop a good intuition of
deep learning as a whole
of course we've only just scraped the
surface there's a whole new world out
there
if you like this course please consider
liking and subscribing it really helps
me make courses like this
i have a couple of videos on computer
vision with opencv that i will be
releasing in a couple of weeks
so stay tuned for that in the meantime
good luck